en plein coeur de chelsea une petite
municipalité de l'outaouais
c'est à l'abri des regards que l'on
retrouve le cimetière board win
dans un décor bucolique quelques pierres
tombales se dressent toujours fièrement
et raconte l'histoire de la famille de
william baldwin un ancien sergent
britannique à qui on avait accordé dans
les années 1800 une terre de 80 hectares
l'équivalent de 115 terrain de football
aujourd'hui encore le cimetière trône au
milieu de cette immense domaine chez
certains surtout chez les anglophones
dans les milieux ruraux y avait une
tradition d'avoir un cimetière familial
les gens se faisaient enterrer près de
leur terre ou sur l'hôpital
ici ce qui est intéressant à chelsea il
y avait déjà un vieux cimetière qui est
aujourd'hui un cimetière historique
alors comme ils étaient protestants ils
étaient métaux 10,6 aurait pu très bien
la famille allait se faire enterrer à
tall chelsea mais je pense que pour leur
attachement l'attachement à leur table
ici à laval et mitchell ont décidé de se
faire enterrer ici l'endroit est bien
cachée est encore méconnu du grand
public le cimetière a presque même été
oubliés puisque personne n'y avait été
enterrée depuis 90 ans
mais l'histoire a changé et là tout à
coup à la faim est dû à 20e siècle 1996
on a de nouvelles sépultures et en fait
on pourrait dire que c'est ainsi matière
en car vivant puisqu'il ya un descendant
de ballerine qui s'est fait enterré ici
en 2019
depuis l'endroit replie ses lettres de
noblesse la municipalité a créé un
parcours pour les visiteurs qui veulent
revivre l'histoire de la région
comme vous allez là et puis vous êtes
fait une randonnée voyez un beau chat
comme c'est beau nous avons qu'une idée
qu'est ce qui était leur auparavant
alors ça me laisse à des famines piani
qu'ils ont
un développeur qui ont participé à la
vie communautaire et la vie civique dans
le gouvernement municipal
et puis tout ça s'est perdu alors là on
a pris un petit peu l'histoire péglé
j'aime ça oui cette initiative permet de
partager aux visiteurs une page
d'histoire de ce coin de pays
ici christian millet à 30 du canada
chelsea en outaouais